[Music]
hey everybody welcome to planet coaster
college in this episode I'll talk about
the arrow looping coaster and show you
how to build one but before I do that I
will have an extra coaster rant about
the background of these coasters because
it's actually quite interesting and
surprisingly relevant when it comes to
making one in the game now you can find
it as the American arrow in the game
which is already very interesting
because arrow here actually refers to
the company that built these in real
life and arrow is a company is actually
seen as one of the biggest if not the
biggest pioneers in the roller coaster
industry they've built the first steel
roller coaster ever they've built the
first steel roller coaster to featured
inversions and they've had countless
other records and invented many other
rides as well and even though they went
bankrupt around the turn of the century
many of the classic rides still stand
and they really have a legacy as well
now what separates this coaster from
many of the other ones in planet coaster
is that most of them are actually very
modern they feature very high-tech
inversions and new trains and track
types whereas the old Aero coaster
actually had its peak somewhere around
the 70s and the 80s there were still
many made in the 90s but around the 70s
and the 80s is really when they were
most innovative and when they were
really up-and-coming so many of these
have much less smooth and less high-tech
layouts and they're much more just
stringing together of different elements
and so in this episode I actually want
to dedicate a bit of attention to how
you can make one of these much more
classic maybe less interesting and
exciting coasters but one that is really
just a traditional and almost nostalgic
kind of ride now as always I want to
raise the station up a little bit from
the ground and in this case especially I
want to make the station a bit longer as
well these coasters usually have about
six or seven cars on the train in real
life and just adding one more segment to
the coaster station allows you to put
six cars on one train these coasters
often have a small section before the
lifts able to just turn around so I'm
going to do something like that in here
as well and something that you might
want to do when you build this coaster
is just split it up at the very small
Eggman's almost in a roller coaster
tycoon kind of sense where you either
just go down or go banking but not make
everything go as fluidly since these
were designed without the use of
computers and people didn't figure out
how to make tracks that smooth yet also
the strike type just can't make very
smooth coasters everything does go a
little bit bit by bit and a bit more
jittery so I have this section where it
goes down right here and only when we're
really flat so I'm going to turn around
and go to what the lift Hill right here
and actually right here I want to have
it yeah have a little bit more toward
the side here so there'll be a bit more
space to work around with so I'm going
to turn off the angle snap here and make
sure that it's not exactly parallel
alongside the station but moves toward
it just a bit which you don't have to do
definitely not but it's something that I
want to do in this case since I'll have
some loopings going in front of the
station and this opens up a little bit
more space to do that
so as for the lift Hill it's just pretty
much like you always have to do just
about 30 degrees should do the job so
I'm going to turn it up to 15 here and
that is just not a 30 degree lift sill
and we can pretty much build this at
this point let's go up to a little bit
less than 30 meters which should already
be quite a pretty good height for this
kind of coaster you do get them quite a
bit lower as well but in this case I do
want a crumb quite a few elements in
this layout so they should do for now
small pre-op section before we turn
around so that we have enough speed to
turn around here and this is kind of
what I mean with not making these causes
too smooth
you normally kind of wants to put some
banking offset over here and maybe have
it turn as you're going into the banking
but in this case you don't want to do
that kind of thing just have a straight
piece of track I just Bank it a little
bit before you go into the curve you can
actually make that a very short piece
like this and then we're just going to
start into the curve again I'm turning
off angle snap here to get it to line up
with the station a little bit more like
that and after this we can go straight
again and that should be the pre drop
section after this we can just go down
and do the
rest of the layout and the first drop
also doesn't really have to be too
smooth just make sure that we're going
down and add a pretty decent angle
something like this and have it go
straight for an entire section and in
many of the newer coasters you would see
that the drop is actually one very fluid
motion but in some of these older
coasters you really see that they're
just completely straight track pieces
here and there now that we have the old
crappy drop in there it's pretty much
time for the first real elements of the
coaster which is going to be a looping
in this case just a regular old vertical
loop and the vertical loops of these
coasters have this very signature
teardrop style to them the ones that the
game gives you as a standard elements
aren't as teardrop styled as they are in
real life I would say that the shape is
100% like they should be but they're
pretty much good enough and it takes a
lot of time to make them yourself I'll
show that later in this video though but
for now just for making things a bit
easier and less time-consuming I'm just
going to put them together with the game
one thing to keep in mind here though is
that you always want the second loop if
you're putting tulips two loops in a row
which you do quite often see with these
kinds of coasters you want to make the
second loop just a little bit shorter so
it goes through it at a similar speed
also fun little effects anybody who
didn't know yet loops actually shaped
like this instead of circles to keep the
forces throughout the entire loop the
same also many of the classic models of
this kind of coaster like the corkscrew
at Cedar Point's or the steam and demon
at Great Escape actually do have just
one loop before they go into the rest of
the layouts you don't really have to
have two loops it's just one of the
things that you can kind of do with this
so what I want to do after this is
actually get an elements like a small
hill or a curve after which you're going
into the corkscrews which is what you
very commonly see on these kinds of
coasters so I'm just going to go up
again and most important thing to always
remember with these kinds of coasters is
to start banking before you go into your
curves and so because I want the other
side of this hill to curve I'm already
going to start banking it before we
actually get into the curve and then
while we have the curve that's going
down actually
want to bank it a little bit more toward
the end because namely these coasters
usually have a bit of a second act where
they get into the corkscrews and they
usually get into the corkscrews from the
banking that you already have of a curve
which might sound a little complicated
but I'm showing it off in a second so
basically we come out of the curve here
and we want the coaster to go into the
corkscrew straight like that but the
issue is if we add a corkscrew in-game
its first going to go flat and then it's
going to go into the corkscrew so we're
going to have to build our own corkscrew
here which isn't going to be too big of
a worry it doesn't have to be smooth or
perfect because generally if your
coaster isn't very smooth and you're on
the right track to permit to build a
pretty good Aero coaster but at this
point it is quite hard to get that
transition rights from a corkscrew into
a curve or the other way around
so what I usually do is for the very
first section from the curve into the
corkscrew I'm gonna turn the banking to
90 degrees I am gonna rotate it three
times to put the side here and also go
up three times which is basically the
diagonal side of the corkscrew make that
a little bit larger kind of depends on
the way it looks from the curve want to
make sure that the transition is really
right right here let's see just about a
size like that should work then I'm
going to turn off angle snap and or I'm
still going to have angle snap on but
I'm going to turn it to 45 degrees which
is how I usually make cork screws and I
just realized this is a little bit of a
belated corkscrew tutorial but um
basically I want to make this section a
bit smaller and at the other side turn
around go down again go to 90 degrees
again other side there we go and that
should be a pretty decent corkscrew it's
not it's by no means perfect but with
some smoothing tool later on you can
definitely make it into a more than
realistic corkscrew especially with some
of the quirks that we have on the side
here can extend that a bit smooth that
out a little bit it just kind of depends
on how things are going it's it takes
some trial and error to get the shaping
of the corkscrew exactly rights but as
you can tell
we definitely have a
corkscrew going on over here also a
quick idea is that a corkscrew always
looks like a zig zag like this from
above so as soon as you have this kind
of profile going on from a bird's
perspective then you pretty much have
the right track shaping of a corkscrew
what you can also do if you're a lazy
bastard is just finish off the top piece
like this make sure that it's exactly
180 degrees and then go to the pre-given
cork screws and at that point you can
just take one of the cork screws that
the game gives you and the second
corkscrew is always a little bit easier
you can just do it the way that the game
gives you the cork screws now for those
of you who are making your own cork
screws a very good way to check whether
the cork screws are decent and smooth
enough is to look down at the side of
the cork screw like this and if you've
got a perfect round spiral going into
the center then the cork screw is more
or less fine there are some
disadvantages to using the in-game
inversions because you can't actually
smooth them out and it just makes things
a lot harder when it comes to coming up
with transitions from other pieces of
track but I've been testing the coaster
and because it's already losing quite a
bit of speed at the cork screws here and
arrow cursors do usually ended with a
helix or a little air dam here after the
cork screws I'm already going to end the
coaster quite soon so I'm going to head
back to the back of the station and
actually finish this before I make the
rest of the track have a very slight
incline and this is where we're going to
have the brake run as well as the block
brakes for being able to run multiple
trains these kinds of courses don't
always run multiple trains but in this
case I kind of do like to do so
especially if you've got one of these
larger Aero corkscrew coasters or Aero
looping coasters you're definitely going
to want to add some lock breaks to be
able to store some extra trains also in
reality very often there's a bit of a
break section right here when the
coaster car slows down and where there's
a transfer track on the side where they
can store the extra train so I want to
have quite a lengthy break run right
here and after that we can return to
where the rest of the coaster is still
hanging so for me here I'm just going to
finish off the coaster in a pretty
simple manner just gonna make one last
hill where it's gonna have a curve as
well so I want to bank it first then
we're going to have a straight section
which is just a curve pretty modular
and after that's we have a section where
it goes flat again and goes to a flat
banking as well alright so I finished
the ride with a quick Heal at the end of
it and just a quick curve to turn around
and get into the break run give it a new
color scheme which is a bit more flashy
and that pretty much just finishes the
ride it's not a recreation of any
existing ride but it's definitely very
similar to many of these rights there
are countless copies of the corkscrew
coaster which is similar to this coaster
except without the loopings right here
there are many double loop double
corkscrew coasters or just loop
corkscrew coasters but um this one is
just kind of a bit of an amalgamation of
all the different things that they have
in common I would say the loops could be
a little bit faster you do see them a
bit faster they could just be smaller
but that aside the pacing in the right
seems quite good especially on the
corkscrew where it just flies through
these things goes into the last hill
right there which has some very awful
banking but that was kind of what I was
looking for and into the last curve
which is a little bit so Sun I would
have probably made a bit more space over
here to get from the banks curve into a
straight piece of track but that aside I
am actually quite happy with it let's do
a POV so we're in it right now and from
the top of the lift Hill going into that
small pre drop section which you also
don't really always have but it's
something which you do see a lot on
these kinds of coasters and helps keep
them somewhat compact it's the first
drop which on this one is actually quite
steep into the double loop which yeah
it's a little bit slow when it comes to
the pacing but that aside works out
pretty well
into what is usually the painful part of
the ride and into the terrible
transitions of the corkscrews and the
curves which as bad as they are are
quite realistic so I'll keep them around
and into the last curve and from that
for the brake run braking a little bit
some log brakes at the end and that is
where we could store the second train if
we wanted to have a second trail ice
actually add one to little block
sections and add a second train that's
where that train is going to want to
wait now here's me trying to capture the
classic
arrow coaster filled with a bunch of
scenery around the coaster just very
simple and very rustic but this is the
kind of thing where you usually see
these kinds of coasters either in a
small theme park or somewhere in the
back of a Six Flags park that they don't
really care about em put VR goggles on
um but yeah usually these are pretty
rustic and very nostalgic kind of rides
and also the blog brakes were a bit of
an issue for me at the left table since
the Train actually cleared the circuit
just after the first car reached the
lift here which means that it's going to
have to wait on top of the lift Hill for
the other coaster car to finish the
block that it's on in which case I just
had turned up the waiting time in the
station 280 seconds and that pretty much
fixed that it's not the greatest thing
and it doesn't give you the greatest
stats either the excitement is just
about 4.5 I believe 4.7 but at least the
fear rating and the noise rating are a
bit lower lower than that any general
the ratings are kind of like a family
coaster not too bad it's not too
expensive over ride either and if you
really want to go for a classic Aero
look even in your career or scenario you
could definitely use it now that would
have been all for this video if I wanted
to leave it at just the coaster that I
made but there's one thing that I want
to add and that's that there are also
larger error loopers which came about
especially in the 90s I still standing
example of it is the Viper but most of
them have already been removed which
broke some records for the largest
inversions etc but um they were pretty
weird coasters because they still used
the elements that arrow was using before
that just on a much larger scale so what
you would see with a looping for example
on many of the arrow mega loopers is
that instead of having a completely
large looping by just taking the in-game
loop and drawing it out like this
the loopings would often first have a
large section where it goes up in a very
gentle way going toward the loop for
quite a while and then you would have
the very standard teardrop shaped loop
so to make one right now would be to
just add this large section going up
like that and then when you get to the
actual loop itself start to rotate it a
bit so you can actually go to the side
make the top and make that very small
just get the teardrop shape in there and
the same goes for the other side right
here again it's very small and then
we're going to make the track a bit
longer again and go down to the other
side which is always a bit tricky
actually because you're going to have to
like rotate it to go to the middle right
here and actually go into the other
direction on the other side of the loop
basically it's going to have to rotate
on the top of the looping and you're can
I have to figure out how the looping is
going to go but you generally want a
looping to look like a set when you look
at it from the top so this one doesn't
have enough zette right there
and I'm going to have to add a little
bit more right here that should just
about do it and then a whole lot of
smoothing and correcting some minor
track pieces shouldn't get the teardrop
shape in there at some point and that's
pretty much how these loopings would be
there are some examples of some really
large Aero loopings that are actually
regularly shaped like the Tennessee
tornado but that's getting into some
completely different things I would
actually say if you're interested in
Aero and how they developed and a bit of
general coaster history as well there is
a documentary of the American coaster
enthusiasts called the legacy of arrow
developments which is a really cool
documentary that you can watch if you're
interested and it can certainly teach
you some stuff about roller coasters as
well just a quick tip anyway that's it
for the weird mega looper looping there
are two more elements that I want to
talk about that you could see on arrow
coasters and that you might want to try
and mess with one of them is the batwing
which is very common elements on some of
these mega loopers and it should already
be a standard element in the game which
you can find like this but I have to say
it's a bit of a strange batwing because
many of the real bat wings enter quite a
lot higher than the lowest point of the
batwing so you can also kind of make
your own bat wing in a sense something
like that and then another loop on the
other side back into another
corkscrew as well and that is basically
a batwing there's also the cut back
which is an interesting element that's
found on dragon fire which is a
corkscrew in and then another corkscrew
out in the same direction so you get a
shape like this anyway that's all I
wanted to say about the arrow looping
coaster thank you guys so much for
watching this and if you have any
feedback or comments don't be afraid to
leave them in the comment section of the
video and I'll see you guys in the next
video